the spider-man far from home trailer is
about to play but if you haven't seen
Avengers end game yet
stop watching because there's some
serious spoilers about to come up but if
you have seen Avengers end game enjoy
the trailer everywhere I go I see his
face just really miss him I miss him too
I don't think Tony would have done what
he did if he didn't know that you were
gonna be here after he was gone
you gonna be in next Ironman now well no
I don't have time I'm too busy doing
your jobs oh I'm kidding I'm kidding
look keep up the good work because I am
going on vacation heads up
Nick Fury's calling you I don't really
want to talk to me at all why because if
you don't talk to him and I have to talk
I don't want to talk about you sent Nick
Fury to voicemail I gotta go you do not
ghost Nick Fury that dorks
what's up we're just talking about the
trip I'm here in San Marco Polo's oh I
think MJ really likes me come on when I
first went alone you're a very difficult
person to contact spider-man
this is mr. Beck we're gonna use someone
like you on my world new world Beck is
from Earth just not ours a snap to our
home in our dimension we have a job to
do you're coming with us
it's gotta be something else you can use
what about the offworld catching her
unavailable but who's defending
neighborhood spider-man
[ __ ] please you've been to space what
do you want Peter I want to go back on
my trip with the girl who I really like
and tell her how I feel
MJ I am spider-man no of course not I
mean it's kind of obvious you're right
you may not be ready but this is my
responsibility
saving the world requires sacrifice
sometimes people die
it's always feel I got putting my
friends to Dana
the world needs next Ironman you're
going to step up or not
[Music]
here building jet I work with spider-man
you were through spider-man I want wet
spider-man not for spider-man
hi everyone its charlie we got a brand
new spider-man far from home trailer to
break down and obviously they give you a
big spoiler warning at the beginning of
that if you haven't seen Avengers in
game big spoilers because they talk all
about Iron Man what's going on during it
so why we see they tease a lot of big
stuff during this they try to say
Mysterio is from the multiverse I'm from
another earth the snap tore a hole in
the fabric of our dimension just
allowing me in all these elementals
quote-unquote to break through so we got
a whole bunch of Easter eggs to break
down here yes I do think that Mysterio
is pulling a fast one on Nick Fury
trying to make everyone think that he's
from another earth but I will talk about
some of the possibilities that Sony is
trying to spin in the background here
because they definitely want Tom Hall
and spider-man in their venom and other
spider-verse movies that they're making
so why would not be surprised if they
are trying to build multiverse out of
this so that someday they could
eventually build to a live-action spider
burst movie like we saw the animated
Spider Man into the spider verse but if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the Marvel videos
we do Easter eggs every week obviously
it's only gonna get crazier as we get
ready for spider-man far from home we
have a Comic Con coming up this summer
and we're gonna get the official Marvel
phase 4 movie scheduled after spider-man
far from home hits theaters well do new
round of the Infinity Gauntlet giveaway
- all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a spider-man
comment on the video but you open the
trailer with spider-man in the iron
spider suit after the events of Avengers
endgame patrolling New York City just
doing his normal friendly neighborhood
spider-man thing last year Amy Pascal
said that the movie picks up minutes
after the end of Avengers endgame but I
actually now think that she's talking
about the Avengers end game sort of end
credits scene where spider-man meets Ned
Leeds post snap like everyone is back oh
my god I can't believe it
what happened they're trying to deal
with it Kevin Feige and the Russos also
confirmed the timeline so like all of
his classmates here this is 2023 it's 5
years later some of his classmates from
spider-man homecoming did not get
snapped they're now 5 years older
they're probably in college or they've
gone on to have jobs but even though
they don't address that during the
trailer they'll probably be a minute at
the beginning of the film where they
have somebody referenced that because
you do see them in class talking about
their trip that they're getting ready to
go on so obviously they're gonna have a
couple scenes with them at school but
because the end of endgame takes place
in the spring maybe there's just like a
quick
montage that takes place that pushes
them into the beginning of summer like
it's the last couple of weeks of school
at the end of Avengers endgame because
they'll all go back they meet each other
is probably just a little time jump
before you see them all aboard the plane
and head to Venice you see him talking
to happy about missing Ironman literally
and figuratively seeing his face
everywhere his eyes are all red so it
looks like he definitely needs a
vacation he's probably been pulling
double time since he came back just to
make up for lost time because he didn't
really know what had happened when he
first came back from the snap dr.
strange explained it to him but there's
this whole thread in the trailer about
him being Iron Man's replacement now
like the cops tell him wait you're gonna
be both Iron Man and spider-man now
because he's wearing the iron spider
suit even Nick Fury tells him he's gonna
step up happy says I don't think that
Iron Man would have done what he did if
he didn't think you'd be around to pick
up the slack when he was gone so a lot
of the early part of the movie is just
him dealing with everyone's expectations
for him because even though it's been
five years and technically they're five
years older he's still 1617 years old so
he still feels like a high school kid so
he's still trying to reconcile all these
big things that are going on but also
still being a high school kid trying to
deal with high school problems like I'm
just trying to tell the girl that I
liked that I liked her during the scene
with the cops one of them is named
Bristow that's actually a character from
the New Mutants comic books which is an
x-men title he became obsessed with
Kitty Pryde dance teacher he didn't have
powers and he wasn't a mutant but I know
a lot of you were wondering how they're
gonna start invoking x-men Fantastic
Four stuff I'm not expecting any big
x-men characters or anything like that
to pop up during this movie but he'll be
surprised if you start seeing little
Easter eggs and references in people's
names and street signs and license
plates like there are a lot of license
plate Easter eggs for sinister six
characters when they're fighting the big
quote-unquote elemental creatures during
this trailer they have the funny joke
about nobody wanting to talk to Nick
Fury Happy's like I'm not talking to him
wait a minute did you just send him to
voice mail you can't do that spider-man
trying to duck out so that he can go
have fun with his friends the poster
behind happy crusher versus Hogan is an
Easter Egg for crusher creel which is
the person that Matt Murdock's father
fought in the ring during daredevil
that's also from the daredevil comics as
well I know crusher creel was on agents
of shield but they're kind of doing
something different with that character
the comic book crusher creel did fight
Matt Murdock's
we get extended versions of some of the
scenes that we saw from the last trailer
with them just smiling at each other
Peter being positive that MJ likes him a
little bit while flash Thompson's
getting hit in the nuts
elsewhere being a douchey tourist
there's a funny line from Ned Leeds
about remembering the first time he fell
in love because apparently during the
course of the movie he's going out with
Betty Brant which is a bit of a comic
book Easter egg because adult comic book
Betty Brant was with adult Ned Leeds
when it was found out that he was the
Hobgoblin it was part of that whole saga
even though I don't expect this version
of Neda Leeds to ever become a version
of Hobgoblin there's a little bit of new
dialogue from Nick Fury you're a hard
man to get ahold of a Spider Man he
takes him to the Venice canals to what
we now know is a secret shield base with
Maria hill and introduces him to the
Quentin Beck Mysterio who apparently
says that he's from an alternate earth
we could really use someone like you on
my earth wait a minute there's a
multiverse in spider-man's brain sort of
exploding as he tries to take it all in
and he's buying it hook line and sinker
so here's where we get to the Mysterio
plot up at all obviously we've heard
what they've said about the character
before this like they said Oh Mysterio
is gonna be hero during this movie but
the new stuff is all this multiverse
explainer they're trying to throw at us
per Mysterio the snap tore a hole in our
dimension allowing all these elemental
creatures and Mysterio to come through
so he's chased them to our earth to help
us clean this up my guess is is that
Nick Fury doesn't totally believe him
and that's why he's got spider-man
double-timing trying to find out what's
really going on follow him around but
when he first pulls spider-man in for
duty here it seems like he totally buys
it but then spider-man through the
course of the film will probably figure
out what Mysterio is really doing they
had the funny moment where he's like I'm
on vacation isn't there somebody else
you could get what about Thor he's
offworld what about Captain Marvel that
new hero that I gave the Infinity
Gauntlet to at the end of Avengers
endgame she's unavailable too obviously
Nick Fury uses the word dimension which
will remind you of spider-man shattered
Dimensions which was inspiration for
comic books spider-verse
which then inspired the spider-verse
movies there are a lot of people that
think that even though Mysterio might be
lying about being from the multiverse
and just using that as cover to try to
explain why he's trying to make himself
look like a hero and really these are
other sinister six characters like
molten man hi
oh man Sandman that long-term Sony's
plan is to build a spider verse in the
movies do live-action stuff it is a way
to explain how they can put Tom Hall and
spider-man in one of their venom verse
movies it would definitely be an easy
backdoor even though I still think that
this version of Mysterio is lying like
comic book Mysterio was because Kevin
Feige MCU movies tend to be pretty
faithful with character origins even
though a lot of times they'll change
comic book storylines a little bit this
just seems like they're using the events
of Avengers infinity war the snap in
Avengers endgame and Iron Man's death to
do the original Mysterio origin story
from the comics where he debuted trying
to make himself look like a hero by
throwing spider-man under the bus only
in this case he's just saying that the
snap tore hole in a dimension there's
always Elemental creatures and that's
what his plan is and the new thing that
they've said about his character because
you see that scene of them talking to
each other commiserating while he's
burning his new stealth suit and
Mysterio's got some of his armor taken
off that the producers the writers
called Iron Man sort of like the cool
dad to spider-man and now they're
calling Mysterio the cool uncle to
spider-man as a mentor type figure
obviously though he's a comic book
villain so there's a very quote-unquote
sinister bent to this to make as many
spider-man puns as possible there's a
scene of MJ watching molten man forming
nearby spider-man swings in wearing his
black stealth suit this might be part of
the prog bite then we see all this
carnival stuff going on in the
background Mysterio flies in tries to
help him you see spider-man try to run
away and jump over this giant explosion
is the multi man creature starts to
chase after him there's a scene of
Mysterio and broad daylight flying past
the shard which also doubles as one of
Nick Fury's bases apparently this is in
London so Mysterio's tech seems pretty
advanced that's pretty accurate to the
comics Quentin Beck in the comics was a
special-effects wizard in Hollywood so
he used a lot of mechanical creations to
fight against spider-man or just make
himself look like more of a hero like
one of the first time spider-man fought
Mysterio Mysterio created a bunch of
fake x-men using robots making
spider-man bite them more footage from
the Mysterio hydro-man fight wall
Mysterio's talking to spider-man in that
bar in Venice about a separate scene
what do you want in life spider-man I
want to tell the girl that I like that I
like her then they
funny seen a Peter maybe trying to tell
her that he likes her how he feels about
her but her swerving on him coming right
out saying he's spider-man oh it's
pretty obvious that you're spider-man
I'm actually happy that they're doing it
this way because they're trying to set
up the MJ character in this movie as a
really smart person of course she would
probably figure out that Peter is
spider-man because at this point in his
career as badass as he is he's totally
bad at the cloak-and-dagger secret
keeping aspect of everything there's a
much larger version of molten man in a
way longer version of the bridge fight
scene at the Tower Bridge of London from
the last big trailer Mysterio flying
into action while spider-man's tour
group runs to safety the scene that
happens right after this is probably the
funny happy scene that they tag at the
end okay we all have to get on the jet
everybody big plan I work with
spider-man Flash Thompson freaking out
wait a minute you work for spider-man
and he's filming it on his camera to
post on social media and happy just
trying to explain to him what his
relationship with spider-man is more
footage of Mysterio explaining how
serious the mission is how this is his
responsibility to see to the end talking
about saving the world how it requires
sacrifice riffing on Iron Man's legacy
saving the universe with the Infinity
Gauntlet the Avengers during endgame
sometimes people die maybe this is
actually when spider-man opens up to him
about his grief at losing Ironman
worrying about putting his friends in
danger because of his secret identity
like I said before spider-man probably
figures out the Mysterio has been lying
to him this whole time he's sort of the
cool uncle mentor type person into
spider-man there's a separate scene of
spider-man playing with Iron Man's
trademark glasses these are the ones
that you saw him wearing during infinity
war then again during Avengers end game
they were made out of nanotech during
that I don't know if this is a separate
dedicated pair or if it's also nanotech
like the ones that Iron Man used but you
see him in the back of Iron Man's jet
from earlier in the trailer with that
special new gauntlet tech on and it
looks like something that Iron Man made
for him maybe that has something to do
with the new versions of his spider
suits that he wears during the trailer
like the black stealth suit and then the
newer black and red suit there's more
devastation from the Sandman fight we
saw a Nick Fury Maria Hill involved in
spider-man says the world needs the next
Iron Man and they're sort of trying to
juxtapose all the stuff that Mysterio is
doing and all the stuff that spider-man
is doing at him seeing Iron Man's face
all over the place like he looks at the
little shrine of
I mean with the candles all around it it
also reminds you that funny scene from
the last trailer where his tour group is
looking at the news footage of Mysterio
biting saying he looks like Iron Man and
Thor rolled into one so I think part of
the idea is is this Spider Man sees this
and it's like oh wow this Mysterio guy
he can pick up the mantle and take all
this responsibility so I won't have to
worry about it that much I can just
still be friendly neighborhood
spider-man but as we're all probably
expecting maybe there's a big Mysterio
swerve during all this he's lying about
it spider-man will have to take him down
and end up stepping up the way that
Happy's telling him and Nick Fury like
Nick Fury literally tells him during the
trailer it's time for you to step up
so everybody let me know in the comments
do you think that Mysterio is lying
about being from an alternate earth and
using the snap and the multiverse and
Avengers end game to try and pass
himself off as a hero with these
elemental creatures that also might be
sinister six characters because of all
the toys they're selling like they're
literally calling this guy molten man
they're literally calling this guy hydro
man's so it does seem like their
backdoor including sinister six
characters there are more Avengers
endgame Marvel phase four and spider-man
videos that I have planned for later
this week but leave all your questions
in the comments below and I'll try to
address those during those videos on
name a new giveaway winner when I post
new Marvel but my next video will be
that Game of Thrones season 8 episode 5
trailer video so look out for that later
today while you wait for everything
click here for my Avengers end game
Easter eggs video and click here for my
Game of Thrones season 8 episode 4 video
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]